bonjour françois de la vie vraiment
merci d'être avec nous cet après midi
sur rt france alors on l'a dit un jean
yves le drian s'est déplacé au mali une
première depuis le 18 août dernier quels
étaient les enjeux de cette visite
ben c'est déjà de tâter le terrain pour
jean yves le drian qui est un habitué du
mali on pourrait même dire que il était
il est très proche des maliens puisqu'il
est quand même à la base est à l'origine
de l'opération serval ou souvenez en
2013 cette opération militaire franco
africaines décidé depuis paris pour
bouter les djihadistes qui avaient
occupé le nord du mali dès 2012 donc
quelque part c'est un artisan de cette
de cette opération militaire française
au mali lent que biz la défense
aujourd'hui depuis quelques années
depuis le président macro et les
ministres des affaires étrangères il est
souvent venu il a de nombreux amis il
avait de nombreux amis au mali notamment
à l'époque de l'ancien président déchu
renversé ibrahim boubacar kéita vous
souvenez renversé donc cet été
maintenant il est bien il fallait qu'il
re les seuils un petit peu de de
raffermir ses liens avec sept nouveaux
ce nouveau gouvernement
ce nouveau président banda un ex colonel
à la retraite qui a été lui même
ministre de la défense sous le président
ib cas et qu'ils étaient bien
très remonté contre l'ancien président
et puis moctar ouane qui est le nouveau
ministre des affaires étrangères que le
nouveau premier ministre par don qui
était l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'ancien président amadou
toumani touré qui avait été lui-même
renversé tous et toutes ces personnes ne
sont pas très proche du bk or l'actuelle
le ministre des affaires étrangères
français le drian est restée très proche
on le sait je vous le répète de ib cas
pourquoi et bien parce que il faisait
partie de cette internationale
socialiste
souvenez-vous ibrahim boubacar keïta a
vécu longtemps en france a beaucoup
fréquenté et bien les socialistes comme
françois hollande laurent fabius et le
drian donc il y avait un lien
particulier à la fois politique
et puis est bien c'est de guerre qui
avait été engagée quant aux djihadistes
aujourd'hui bien il fallait pour le
drian et c'était de savoir à qui l'afer
depuis que cette ce gouvernement a été
mis en place
la françois-xavier effrayante vous venez
d'en parler un la guerre contre le
terrorisme
au mali on se souvient il ya quelques
semaines pour la libération de sophie
petrona et soumaïla cissé plusieurs
centaines de personnes réclamées par les
jihadistes avait été libéré est ce que
justement jean yves le drian vient au
mali pour demander des garanties sur le
combat à mener contre les djihadistes
oui des garanties parce que on voit bien
que l'actuel gouvernement un petit peu
changé de stratégie
la libération de ben et ronin et du chef
du leader de l'opposition
soumaila cissé sont la preuve que ils se
sont rapprochés un petit peu des
mouvements jihadistes ont tous les cas
il ya un dialogue secret qui s'est créée
notamment on le dit ici et là par le
biais de l'imam dicko vous savez cet
imam salafiste formée en arabie saoudite
qui est très très écouté aujourd'hui au
mali notamment dans les milieux
populaires et qui faisait partie bien de
cette du mouvement jeu du mouvement m5
vous savez ce mouvement de contestation
en tout cas qu'il a un petit peu piloter
et qui a fini par faire tomber le
président ali ben ibrahim boubacar keïta
donc on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
du côté des autorités maliennes il ya
une volonté peut-être de régler les
problèmes à la malienne
j'irai même à l'africaine c'est à dire
eh bien peut-être tendre la main
notamment un jihadiste où un terroriste
très recherchées notamment par les
français
iliad a gravi vous savez cet ancien
rebelle touareg qui domine toute la
région de kidal donc le nord de du mali
et qui frappent régulièrement aux quatre
coins du pays avec avec son son groupe
djihadiste donc il il est clair que du
côté français une opposition à cette
stratégie
la france fait la guerre
aux terroristes depuis maintenant 2013
depuis sept ans a priori d'après ce que
j'ai cru comprendre la ligne française
ne change pas on ne veut pas de dialogue
avec des terroristes on estime qu'il
faut revenir et bien à 7 à ce contrat
qui avait été écrit avec les différents
mouvements séparatistes malien lors des
accords d'alger pour éventuellement
essayer de désamorcer cette crise au
nord du pays où on voit que il ya une
petite tension à ce niveau là entre
paris bamako
autre sujet avant de nous quitter
françois-xavier frais l'andes une autre
un autre sujet aujourd'hui
pour jean yves le drian est la signature
de conventions des de développement du
mali à hauteur de 140 millions d'euros
on imagine que c'est un symbole fort un
pur pour les deux pays oui on sait très
bien que de manière on n'arrivera pas à
en finir avec le terrorisme sans une
coopération sans une aide au
développement dans un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde et dans une des régions
les plus pauvres du monde
évidemment la france l'a compris depuis
longtemps il faut apporter du
développement dans ces régions
complètement oublié un notamment du nord
ou frappe ici là depuis maintenant
presque une dizaine d'années les
mouvements jihadistes et où l'état
malien a du mal à revenir en termes
d'éducation en termes de développement
économique social etc et on sait très
bien que les djihadistes et l'islamisme
radical se nourrit de ce fossé de cet
abandon des populations au nord du pays
pour grandir son aura pour approfondir
son influence sur toute cette région et
sur le reste de la zone sahélienne
merci françois davy frais l'andes
d'avoir été avec nous cet après midi sur
arte france je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et auteur de malice au
dollar du djihad aux éditions anne à
mozac merci beaucoup